agencies across the globe including the
southern nevada health district are on
omicron watch the health district's
director of disease control and
surveillance dr cassius lockett says
there's an active surveillance program
here locally capable of detecting the
new variant genomic sequencing is always
necessary in fact our southern nevada
public health lab the state lab and
several of our
contractors that we work with that do
routine laboratory testing on our behalf
they have the ability to sequence right
now so we are ready the southern nevada
water authority and scientists at unlv
are also testing waste water dr lockett
says the best way to protect ourselves
is to continue with the current
mitigation efforts which include
vaccines booster shots mask wearing
indoors and social distancing there's no
need to panic at this point there's a
lot of unknowns in the u.s the delta
variant is still the dominant strain the
cdc recommends everyone ages 18 and up
to get the booster shot you can find the
nearest clinics on the health district's
website simply by searching your zip
code hector mejia reporting live local
now